it's incredible the connection between
fiber and our gut microbiome fiber
doesn't just go in the mouth and shoot
out the other end soluble fiber is a
specific sort of General category which
feeds the microbiome this is their
preferred food and when we give this to
them they grow stronger our microbes
actually multiply grow stronger and then
they turn around and they reward us and
the way that they reward us is by
releasing short chain fatty acids short
chain fatty acids optimize our immune
system they can have their effect in the
lungs on the immune system I mean
believe it or not we have studies that
suggest that they prevent Alzheimer's
disease these are incredibly powerful
and the way that you get them is through
the consumption of fiber in your diet
and here's the problem 97 of Americans
are not getting an adequate amount of
fiber in their diet and that's creating
issues for us everybody's worried about
their protein intake but they don't give
a second thought to their fiber intake
97 of people are fiber deficient that's
a shocking statistic